ever wish you could get a second attempt
at an awkward convo or maybe run a whole
day back just do it better yeah I feel
you and in case you haven't heard Madame
web is the latest superhero in the Sony
Spider-Man universe and she can
literally see the future and then like
do something about it of course in her
case it's about spotting an evil baddy
and saving people's lives not just doing
a better job of talking to a crush but
hey we all have our battles I thought
I'd take a look at what we know so far
about all the battles emotional and
literal in this upcoming flick so let's
start with something maybe we shouldn't
be that concerned with but totally are
the movie's runtime these days it's a
big deal when a movie has a notable
runtime killers of the flower Moon I'm
looking at you the Madam web run time
was leaked recently and it's coming in
at 116 minutes just a few shy of a full
2 hours now it's not that notable that a
superhero movie would have a longer run
time but it's notable that it's the
longest so far of the assorted flicks in
the Sony Spider-Man universe morbius
clocked in at 104 minutes while Venom
Let There Be Carnage was a mere 97
minutes so maybe it's a hint that Sony
is liking what they're seeing and
willing to keep it lengthy so who is
madam Webb and what's this movie about
well for starters the powers that be are
doing the usual routine of keeping a
tight lid on most things about the movie
so what we know so far comes mostly from
the comics and the trailer in the comics
Madam Webb first arrived in 1980 an
Amazing Spider-Man number 210 she's a
mutant with the ability to see into the
future and while she doesn't have the
same Spidey powers that Peter Parker has
she's been in and out of the Spider-Man
narrative ever since her Alter Ego is
Cassandra Webb who in the movie at least
is a paramedic in NYC and she's played
by Dakota Johnson essentially Madame web
is a standalone Universe early in the
trailer Cassandra realizes she can see
into the future though it seems to be
strictly about dangerous and deadly
things coming not like the lottery
numbers when's that movie coming Sony
she sees an evil baddy walk onto the
subway and start attacking three girls
so she quickly convinces them to jump
off the train before that can happen
what unravels is a battle against this
bad guy named Ezekiel Sims and played by
tahar Rahim as he comes after the four
gals in various ways and of course
Cassandra AKA Madame web uses her
precognition abilities to their
advantage though from the looks of it
she might have some physical Powers too
speaking of physical danger Dakota
seemed to take to the dangerous elements
of filming she talked about how she did
her own stunt driving at least for one
day of shooting and according to her it
went great she said quote I drove an
ambulance I drove a taxi cab I drove
everything in the movie except for
flying through the air and out of a
building but other than that I'm like
watch out Tom Cruz sure makes sense
Johnson is joined by a fun cast of young
actresses including Sydney Sweeney as
Julia Carpenter now fans of the comics
know that name Julia's Alias is
Spiderwoman so that puts an interesting
spin on things yes further comic
afficianados might note that at least in
the comics she actually becomes Madame
Webb at one point so maybe that's down
the line in a sequel or two then there's
Isabella mered playing Ana corason AKA
Arna as well as Celeste OK Conor playing
Maddie Franklin and yes if your
particular Spiker sense is tingling as
you hear those character names you're
not alone those are both the names of
characters who have also been
Spiderwoman or spider girl this is
likely not a coincidence people and it's
even hinted at during the trailer at one
point Ezekiel Sims references what these
girls all become and apparently he's
fighting to make sure that doesn't
happen and it wouldn't be a blockbuster
superhero movie if it didn't also have
some famous names playing smaller parts
too Adam Scott zosa mammo Mike EPs and
Emma Roberts all all make appearances if
you've ever watched BTS footage of a
Marvel or Sony Spider-Man movie you know
that a lot of it is done with a colored
screen in the background often it's
green sometimes blue no big issue there
but jumping in front of those things for
the first time as an actor is still a
daunting task Dakota found this out
pretty quickly and discovered she had
strong opinions about it in an interview
with indiewire she said quote I've never
really done a movie where you are on a
blue screen and there's fake explosion
is going off and someone's going
explosion and you act like there's an
explosion Dakota even referred to the
process as absolutely psychotic she kept
wondering if the movie was going to be
any good and at the same time hoping she
was doing a decent job of acting in
front of the nothingness of the blue
screen though it wasn't all scary in a
bad way she was asked about it last year
and said it was a wild experience I
learned so much I'm sure there will be
one day coming soon where a flood of
interviews and info about madam web gets
released but until then they're being
the usual level of tight lipped here's
Sydney when she was asked about it last
year
anything I can't say anything same goes
for Dakota when an interview tried to
squeeze out any info possible I can tell
you pretty much nothing I can tell you
nothing Dakota has at least talked about
what her Indie and small film experience
brought to Madam web I can bring maybe
some stuff from that I I want to see in
and she also literally brought along
certain crew members from her indie film
chaa real smooth to Madam web people
from chaa team of people that make
movies I don't know about you but I feel
like at this point I can see into the
future also and say I'm going to be
seeing Madam web fine so that's not
exactly a superpower but it's a solid
prediction have any thoughts about this
upcoming movie pop them in the comment
section